so you mentioned earlier that you worked
with don t have your project joseph
gordon-levitt zooey deschanel and then
you've also worked with Mark Harmon Jon
Cryer what's the casting process like
these people I mean are you having them
reef in these parts or you're just right
into their people well I think every
project is different you know every
project in how its put together like for
instance manic I had very little to do
the casting of it I was just a writer
you know that had a small part in the
movie that was pretty much the extent of
my my say but of course I'm loud and
opinionated so they would hear my
opinion whether it mattered or not but
with that like my first film's movie
called outside sales which very low
budget and it literally was cast through
phone calls to actors that I worked with
in this theatre company so pretty much
all of that that there were all people
that I knew my next film which was
weather girl was a higher budget and we
had a casting director and basically we
ended up bringing on Jane Lynch who had
worked with my producer before and she
came in and did like a one-day scene but
once she agreed to do it it became very
easy to go out to name talent because
they all want to work with jane lynch
and Jane Lynch is a really nice stamp of
approval so we were able just I mean you
know you don't make more Carmen audition
for anything but we had sat down had
coffee which is the sophisticated way of
doing it here in Hollywood I guess he
said I don't have some tea um but and
then with the six month rule it was
pretty much all offers I think I yes it
was all offers we just went around found
the talent that we wanted to work with
had some conversations luckily I got to
meet with a couple of the actors before
we locked it in and then they all flew
down to Louisiana to do a movie with me
you